[Música]
cuál fue el día que más perdido se
sintieron con su vida transporten sea
este momento en donde todo lo que no
tenía que cambiar cambió
el mío sucedió cuando tenía 19 años
estaba en un cibercafé papá hace años se
ha habido vivir en eeuu con la promesa
de volver y recibir un mail que decía
hija te escribo ante la dificultad de
decírtelo en persona me caso
imagínense el miedo las sensaciones el
santo queriendo salir
respondí como pude con silencio
qué realidad no era un silencio en
conversaciones privadas
porque me había hecho a mí
porque había tomado esa decisión
y así pase el tiempo y el silencio como
todos los reyes silenciados tiene un
revés y sucedió cuando luego de tres
años acepte un viaje a su tierra
haití junto a mi hermana
en este momento yo veía a mi papá como
alguien omnipotente alguien magnánimo
distinguido esas personas que uno le
tiene tanto respeto que se puede parecer
el miedo
cuando llegue a haití encontró una
realidad que nunca antes había visto
imaginen
un centro sin asfalto
imaginen una única calle y un país sin
horarios
imaginen cabeza de los niños grandes y
pastas hinchadas
por hambre
estar haití
quizás ver a mi papá imaginar su
infancia
me hizo verlo de otro modo más
vulnerable más sensible
de este lado más cercano
en este momento la relación con mi papá
volvió a ser quizás hasta mucho más
profunda de lo que era antes
ahora con esa
la nueva esposa no está así que no le
iba a aceptar no y verás cenas me voy a
conversar ella para mí va a ser mi
rebelión declarada mi mayor acto de
transgresión ella representaba el cambio
que yo no podía ni quería aceptar y ahí
se había plantado bandera
y así entre otra etapa la etapa de los
hijos tengo cuatro hijos y mi hijo mayor
me costó un embarazo de dos años y ocho
meses mira él
dos años y ocho meses de una búsqueda
constante de lograr traerlo de haití
cada vez que teníamos una noticia de una
noticia negativa junto a mi marido a mi
familia seguiremos esperando que algo
pasará para que caer pudiera estar en
casa
un día volvió a llamar papá y me dijo
hija lamento decirte que no vamos a
poder avanzar con la adopción
en este momento mi contención emocional
estaba dada por mi familia incluyendo mi
papá pero aparte mi papá representaba un
soporte logístico tremendo yo no hablo
el idioma haitiano que es el creole y
necesitaba de él para hacer trámites
para entender la idiosincrasia para
recorrer ministerios embajadas
entonces decidí viajar una vez más a
eeuu donde vive papá para ver que
podríamos hacer
repasamos todos los escenarios que
parecían imposibles
guys en este momento sufría desnutrición
raquitismo
le costaba correr
le costaba caminar
y en este momento la innombrable me dijo
que esta compañía
esa también haitiana
y dije bueno ok monas vamos
y así fue como mola en los próximos días
en haití y recorrimos hospitales que
dieron testigos del estado de salud de
gael
fuimos a embajadas
y entramos un 13 de noviembre del 2013
las 13 horas por última vez a la
embajada argentina pidiendo por favor
que le dejaran venir a casa
a las 15 de la tarde ese día daily show
valíamos a casa
saludamos a mona nos despedimos de ella
de alguna forma mona se había vuelto
alguien vital en nuestra vida a partir
de ese momento gracias a ella ya había
logrado conquistar algo que hasta ese
momento parecía imposible
y porque le cuento esta historia
bueno porque de alguna forma veo la
historia de la transformación la
dinámica de las transformaciones en
bebidas en la dinámica de las
organizaciones de las empresas de los
proyectos
en estas transformaciones siempre
aparece el miedo como la base humana que
condiciona los traccionar que
condicionan nuestro sentido de evolución
el mismo miedo que yo sentí en cada
embajada en cada ministerio ante cada no
el mismo medio que tenemos los humanos a
todo lo que no conocemos a la vejez a
decir te amo a decir no esta identidad
y eso tiene una explicación en nuestra
anatomía nuestro cerebro a grosso modo
se divide en tres partes y el cerebro
reptiliano el que es el encargado de
administrar y gestionar el miedo en
nosotros es el que nos dice no hasta que
haya una seguridad que nos permita
avanzar y probar algo que sea nuevo
pero no solo la condición humana le
cuesta el cambio si nosotros observamos
la naturaleza y nos detenemos en el
ciclo de vida del insecto por ejemplo la
mariposa vamos a ver que muchos hablamos
de la oruga y la mariposa en la etapa de
la oruga el insecto está completamente
fue realizado en alimentarse en crecer
en nutrirse su único foco su desarrollo
y el aumento de su tamaño en la época de
la mariposa el único foco es cerrar el
ciclo adulto de su vida y reproducirse
pero en el medio está el ciclo del
capullo o de la pupa como se conoce en
el cual el insecto se va hacia adentro
pasa días sin comer
sufre dolor y completa el proceso de
reorganización morfológica
realmente el proceso de metamorfosis
un proceso que solo atravesándolo le
permitirá llegar a la vida adulta
tengo la fortuna de liderar junto a un
equipo maravilloso de gente una
organización de 6000 personas
y muchas veces veo talento tremendo
orgullo ando sin animarse evolucionar
será que
nos encontramos muchas veces diciendo yo
lo haría mejor que mi líder
pero sin embargo no lo hicimos no lo
hacemos probablemente nunca lo haríamos
pero consciente o inconscientemente nos
alojamos en este espacio de confort que
nos da no cambiar
y yo creo que tiene que ver con el miedo
creo que tiene que ver con que el miedo
nos genera dolor
y creo que también este dolor cuando le
ponemos el nombre de un otro en lugar de
ponerlo como algo propio como algo
nuestro que nos pertenece
nos hace pensar que es imposible
atravesarlo
también creo
el nivel de compromiso
es lo único que le otorga la seguridad a
este cerebro reptiliano
si yo hubiese parado ante cada no en la
historia de gael
si él hubiese parado ante cada no en
nuestra historia
ninguno de los dos estaríamos juntos
que me enseñó mi historia
me enseñó a tener miedo
pero al tenerlo de verdad
y a tener un miedo que hoy transportó mi
vida profesional yo sé tener miedo y una
capacidad por qué tener miedo nos
permite conocer partes de nosotros
mismos
de otra forma no conoceríamos
qué es lo único que sí me arrepiento de
mi historia
los tres años que perdí con papá
cómo termina la historia feliz porque
porque muchos de los protagonistas
logramos de alguna forma de venir a
mariposas
y en cuanto a mona bueno sigue teniendo
esta mirada de la esposa nueva de papá
espero que todos los días en la mirada
de gael se vuelve una mirada agradecida
llena de sentido en la salud y en la
vida de mi hijo
yo creo
que el mejor regalo que le podemos dejar
el mundo de afuera es nuestra
transformación
y por eso de alguna forma les deseo a
todos ustedes una nueva esposa para su
papá muchas gracias
[Aplausos]